Element Uuh, that’s ununhexium, 116, is
a triumph for the new
nomenclature system, the way of trying to
bring together these
competing labs who were trying to synthesise
these elements. Because
the discovery of Uuh was announced simultaneously
by a Russian lab in
Dubna and the Lawrence Livermore Lab in the
United States showing
that, at last, collaboration had come together
and scientists of all
countries were working together to try and
understand the chemistry of
these elements. What exactly the chemistry
of Uuh is, is still unclear but
again, using Mendeleev’s ideas we can see
that this is going to be in the
same group as oxygen, sulphur, tellurium,
polonium and so Uuh will be
rather more reactive than, or radioactive
than, polonium but will have a
similar sort of chemistry.